HE'S IN THE
AS HIS MATES CHANGE.
CONNOR C
JEREMY SWAYMAN POUNCES ON
IT.
BACK TO THELL THISS
>> DAVID PASTRNAK KN
AND OTTAWA UNABLE
OTTAWA.
>> Garry: THE ONE THING THAT'S
IMPROVED ALONG WITH THE GETTING
MUCH HELP,
WE SAW SOME GOOD SCORING CHANCES
IN THAT PERIOD, BUT THERE WAS A
LOT OF STUFF IN THE NEUTRAL
ZONE, KIND OF LIKE A
GETS THE PUCK AND CENTRED AHEAD.
KICKED BY TKACHUK.
BUT HE'S ON HIS ZAITSEV.
STUDNICKA WILL CHASE AFTER IT.ND
LAYS IT OUT INTO THE SLOT.
IT'S A MATTER OF DeBRUSK
GETTING IT ON TO THE AND
WENT OUT TO THE POINT.
NOW THEY'RE
AND THAT HOPEFULLY WILL GET
UNDER.R.
BERGERON TRYING TO DIG IT FREEDF
THE BRUINS' ZONE.
McAVOY CLOSE TO THR
ZUB.
LOOKS ACROSS.
STUTZLE GIFTS T BOX.
BOUNCE THAT COMES IN FROM BEHIND
PERIOD NORMALLY THAT IS NOT ONE
PAUL SHOOTS THE PUCK INTO THE
BRUINS' END.
HERE'S STUDNICKA.
RUN OUT OF ROOM
PAD DOWN TO STOP HAULA.
>> Garry: CARLO WAS A GUY WE
OTTAWA THE IN.
ENNIS AHEAD.
STUTZLE WAITS.
BACK TO SLIDE IT INTO THE
HALL FOR CONNOR BROWN.
BROWN FINDS A TRAILER!
THEY SCORE! VISION.
LAZAR HAD ALL KINDS OF ROOM AND
HE SHOT IT WIDE! OF OVERTIME.
LITTLE THREE ON THREE.
>> WELCOMEO GETN.
TAYLOR HALL COULDN'T GET THE
SHOT AWAY.